Hi, welcome.
I'm my colleague, Francisco.
We're both
computer engineering students at Buenos Aires University. We
work for inti, which is a
software consultant, and now I
'm going to show you what this is all about.
Well, first, I'll walk around a little bit.
index we are going to present the problem
talk a little bit about what we are
facing we are going to review
let's say base and we are going to see hmm if it
is crf and everything that has to do with
recurrent networks then well we are going to
arrive at the final solution  of the model and
we are going to go to the conclusions and they are going to
be happy and they are going to ask a
lot of questions
well first a medium review
above syntactics and semantics
syntactics deals with the rules of the
language since we are talking about the
programming language of any
language let's say it has to do with how
we are going to order those words for
example something the dog car has a
bad without incorrect tactics but the
car j  play happy has a correct
syntax and semantics deals with the
meaning of the texts for example the
car plays happy does not make much
sense despite the fact that its syntax is
correct the dog plays happy is
clear and the dog kills happy has a
darker meaning  so well that
would be the idea that we are going to be at
our concepts all the time well
the problem of our client is that he
has hundreds of thousands of documents in
different formats like that without any
metadata or data well if he has something but
the idea is almost raw  it is to present it, let's say, to a
client in a pleasant way
so that he can explore it and search for what he
needs.
in a rather cloudy format,
it varies quite a bit, so
well, what we say is
that receiving our texts, all the
texts  They have a general structure
based on their syntax and semantics, for
example, the stories are divided into an
introduction, a knot, an ending,
the news is divided into a pompadour, and all that that
they did to us in primary school,
well, all the texts follow
their rules and some are more
structured  according to how it has
to be and others less an example of a
good we don't but I didn't say it
we are not going to be showing the documents
with which he and our client
due to an nba
but we are going to be giving them an
idea through  different examples
so the first example that comes to mind
of a text whose
structure is highly standardized
is that of papers, for example in this
case we have to say the second
title is below the hierarchy of the
first title that the content is
below  in the hierarchy of the subtitle and if
this came to us in plain text it would be
quite easy to identify it because there is
like a keyword part of  the
syntax precisely that would be in front
of each one of the titles that tells us
to what level each thing corresponds.
Imagine now that this comes in plain text
but without that keyword, what would
have to be done in some way is
to realize with the semantics that the
title that is down there is on the same
topic as the title that was up there
so it is down in the hierarchy to do
that in a country would be very complicated because it
is a complex semantics of a
very wide vocabulary very beachy and
even a person himself does not
realize it  that goes under what but well it
is the first example another example of
highly structured text and perhaps with a
higher hierarchy in the laws the
laws are divided into chapter titles and
more interesting for the purpose of let's say to
exemplify what our client has
is that  within the chapters
the content is also divided into
its own sections that are at the same
level of hierarchy as the
articles  back in this case it would be
if we had this this in
plain text it would be quite
easy to identify quite easy to identify where
an article begins and an article ends because
we have that word that like the article
with an article 2 article 3 etc.
let's imagine again that this comes without
the key word that helps us to
identify then more or less by eye
we can realize that there are
three articles there because because the
articles usually start in the laws
with short phrases or with nouns and
a point let's say that they detail more or
less than  that the article is going to be talking about,
for example, there we see
consumer object comparison after
supplier after consumption relationship
normative integration pre-eminence and
that is how the articles are lived
then it would perhaps be a little
easier in this case for an algorithm
the machine let me identify those
sections
we would escape what regular expressions would be
because and  we will not have the
word gravity no we could not do
much but here not only the semantics help us
but also the syntax helps us a
little
the last example to give us an idea
with some other characteristic that
we have is this which is a transcript by
judgment of  homicide in the usa seems to
be a fairly famous trial because it was
the first result of a and what we
can see is that we have a subtitle
and inside again we have sections
that we say are in the same
hierarchy and that divide that text
but what is interesting about  these sections
is to do as a kind of
dialogue as if it were a
play or as if it were the
murder trial transcript we have questions
we have answers we have
interruptions from the judge there is something that
says about the court that I don't know who the court will be
but  let's say it's like there is a
dynamic and we can already start thinking
that if we identify that
a question was coming it is very likely  that
a question does not come after the
question then we can start to
think something about
transition probability now later we will
be looking at that summarizing the
characteristics of
our clients' documents they are as follows
we have a finite number of sections
of a document or  a document has been given
it is not that we can
understand the hierarchy until
we know how far it can extend
we do not know what section we can
find we will find 34 sections
5 fixed and those are the sections of the
documents then the section of the
documents depends so much  from the syntax
as you saw when those
types of keywords were present that were easy to
say some network xxi comes from the
semantics as we saw when we took
the keywords out of it and also from the
context as we saw in the last case
let's say that if one came one
question clearly what follows is an
answer or not but it does not follow a
question well all  The documents
have the same types of sections,
these hundreds of thousands of documents are
of the same type, they are standardized under
the same rules, so they look
like laws, that is, they have to have
their articles, they have to have their
chapters, they have to have their titles,
there are  dialogues between types of sections
what is this that was established in the
last example that is that we are also going to
have a
question-answer thing or as if it were
a play and there are no
keywords that indicate what for each
part is the text or if there are any out there
I don't know the guy wrote such a
document so throughout the
entire document he uses the same
keyword to identify that but
then in another document if he uses another
keyword or in another document
sometimes  it is there sometimes it is not there or if they use
both
then as a murky medium and a line
of plain text cannot be in two
sections
well because we wanted to do this the
pr  The first reason is we have a
plain text we want to present it to the
user we could want to build an
index they give us a text we give them an
index and they click there later
in any part of the index and the
link takes them to the part of the text that
corresponds to that  it could be a first
reason later if we take, for example,
the description of today's talk if
we more or less if this is
highly standardized and we know
more or less what to expect from some
sections what we can do is say
well once we identify them
we take  and we put a template in it and
you can see much more and then we have the
index we have the text put
in a template since we gave it a
format something that was a txt
but also if you see this let's say
what we have identified there
is a  description is a subheading
the authors audience level
so once we
identify this from the plain text
our usu  Let's say let's send
each of these texts to a
different database like this to different microservices and
they put together a large chain let's say
that it works with this where the user
can be able to search by
audience level who are the speakers or the
words that are  in the description
there we send the description to one or the
abstract to a classifier and then
they will be able to search by topic of the talk
or we can say well, find me the
most similar abstract to that and so
let's say for the value that it adds this is
that  this is in the color
of our client's product,
well,
as a trivial means,
but so that the positive one gets used to it
, we are going to say defect in
long sections or sequences and
use it to present it to the user, well,
when we face this
problem, well, they are going to  see what we were
dealing with but what we ended up
finding was six parts for chan
kim of sequences in the post
aguilar time issue and arran  We go based on that,
for example, inert, here it is name entity
recognition, which recognizes, let's say, the
named entities that would be place names,
etc., etc.,
for example, in this example, édgar dive
dykstra got intoxicated eating a choripán
on the waterfront, he writes, you distract a
person, the waterfront is the place  and those
are the named entities, no, so
our task would be reduced if
we had a magical model there in the
middle to pose it, what we would have
to do is assign some leiber to each word
because it is a classification problem,
something has to be
the citizen has  that being lives something
has to be dykstra it has to be
intoxicated so with him
the different the different conventions
to make those laws let's see the
first one the first one is called yota king
as you can see the first three
words are inside people the rest is
the inside outside the rest south side
except waterfront which is in sight place
then bu  eno it is quite easy to see
that we can extend this to the number of
entities on behalf of the one we want
and with let's say doing the different
times in this way the second
convention is go tagging we have good
well personalize and personalize the
person and there it goes well place and what
what we ended up realizing is how
we had that a line
could only be from one section later
when we are going to propose the
models we are going to see what we say
what we did was we classified by
words in these long sequences and
then we said well this line  what
type will it be in a post processing well
if most of the tags were such and
what do I know but let's say if what
we wanted was to classify the
lines why not instead of proposing
a sequence of words we proposed a
sequence of lines then this  it would be
an example for the case of the laws that
we saw with me also all that is inside the
article we can notice
I t  it also has a limitation when
there are two contiguous sequences of the same
type we cannot identify where
one begins and the other ends in this
case there is where article 2 starts says and
article leaves and we have no way of
knowing
where it is linked to the other so
as in  domain of our problem
there are contiguous sections of the same type
we are forced to use at least
bayo tagging where we can
identify a wine there are other
more complex types of tagging it is alive and new
more so it takes one that
someone else will have tried  he will be going
around for some paper we use
this because it is what gave us the best
results so we are going to continue
the talk with mayo it is very
good and the country
would look more or less like this the
sad ones arrive pdf html we pass them to text
plane and the txt the cham that we love all
all this let's say our client
had it before let's say the contrast of
our solution we are doing it c  with
a solution that there was chacón re exis
so later on to see that as
good as I am good we are going to classify
all the elements of a sequence
instead of classifying a sequence of
words our problem is to
classify sequences of lines and one
last clarification because it  they will
see everywhere
although our problem is not
tagging for the purposes of, let's say, to make
the examples simple and so on when
you see the models you will continue to
see the tags well people and without six
people in the place and you will see the
same example that you just saw from nerd
tagging we are going to use that
throughout the talk as a common thread
for an example to show the
models and well now my partner is going to be
missing well well a little review of those
words that are going  to be our
sequence in the case of marta ying and they are going
to be our observables in the
case when we work with lines
clearly the words we have to
find in some
numerical representation that allows us to do something with
it because we cannot give it the word
a model the representation that we are going to
use is of course going to be edge
mèdiques so
that's good that's good if you don't know what it
is I'll give you one more idea  or less
conceptual worden bedding is a
word mapping of a word in an
n-dimensional space for example
if in dimensions where within that
vector space the words end up
having and end up having relationships
that are nice to back to
work with them be  relationships in
some way based on their
semantics and let's say actually
based on the various that we find in
the corpus with which we train so
for example men things will happen
like synonyms being at a
very small cosine distance and
inside me  magic of a hyper spheres since
there is a word the synonyms will be
just here
and let's also say the distances he cooked
between two words that have a
relationship will ideally be similar if this works
out between the to the kitchen distance
between two words that have the same
relationship for example the cosine distance
between man and woman will be similar to the
sine distance between king and queen in
English  We already know another example of country
capitals, well, Spain, Madrid, Italy,
Rome, and all those cosines will also be similar,
so well, now I
am not seeing anything, my colleague
Solís Solís,
the idea is to give a mini intuition of the
different models that were
composing our final model.  and for
that we are going to do well I repeat diffusion
in er tagging that the idea is we have a
sequence of words because we have a
sequence of words and we want to
get a welsch law sequence
associated with each of the words
in the beginning we could grab and
decide to do  a classifier that
classifies each word
independently of the others,
so even if we had  the best
classifier of all the word
would always be associated with a single tag and
obviously we did not have information on the
context of the words that surround them,
so we could say add a
window with the context of certain
words on one side and on the other and
there we would be incorporating  the
dependencies with the words that
surround them but we would still not be
integrating the structure of the problem,
which is, for example, that an inside person
cannot come from a car but
has to come from a person or another
person
the structured classifiers such as the
hidden marked  models or conditional random
fields allow us to capture that structure
we are going to start by seeing who marked
models to pass to conditional random
feels good the first thing we are going to see
is a frame chain that basically
can be seen as a graph in which the
are not states and the  edges are
probabilities of transition from one
state to another and the magic of this is that
it has q  We had to respect the
frame property that says that the probability of
passing from one state to another only
depends on the state you were in,
but on the entire list of
previous states through which you came,
obviously each state the edges that
leave have to add up to 1 because  If so,
you have to go somewhere good, the
difference with the plug of the
models framework is that these states
are actually hidden and that what
is shown to us is through observable states,
which in our case are going to
be the words or  the vocabulary that
we have
and from that we are going to
want to infer the states have to
continue respecting the framework property
and what we are going to seek to estimate
are the emission probabilities and the
transition probabilities the
transition probabilities would be
the same probabilities  that the
frame faces move from one state to another
and this models what the
detailed structure of our problem would look like
for example, if we have places that are
generally going to be a single
word argentina costanera córdoba
will have more probability of a place
and not an outside than going to an insight
place
and if we have a person who is
generally going to be accompanied by
another name or  for a surname you will have
a little more probability of going to an
insight person than going to a site,
obviously this is an example of
the ones that are drawn, but it is the idea
of ​​what you are looking to model and also, for
example, if we want to model what  from a
to get to an inside the place you cannot
come from anything other than a bin
place or inside place we put zero the
transition probabilities that come
from the other states
well then they are the
emission probabilities that are for a hidden state
which  It would be the distribution of the
observables, that is, the probabilities
that each word will come out, for example, and if
we are inside person, it will never be
intoxicated, but capable in our data.  set
there is a juan costanera flight like this and it is to see he
lives sometimes he appears he changes places
for less there are people sometimes a good
person
if we put all that together we have a
model framed guide
and assuming that the distribution that
our pd that our observables are
independent of each other  we can give a
sequence of observables and a sequence
of hidden states estimate the
joint probability which would be
simply multiply the
emission probabilities by the
transition probabilities of the entire
sequence so if we had
only one sequence of observables
we can stripe to the combinatorics of
all  possible hidden states
calculate all the
joint probabilities and keep the sequences
hidden states that give us the
highest probability in practice it
is not done by brute force but uses
viterbi which is an algorithm that is good
enough but the idea is
good but the sheet  framework models
have problems the main problem  a
is that it assumes that to model the
joint distribution it assumes that the p of
x are independent of each other which is
false the words are not
independent of each other because I have
the clearly after the good an
adjective a noun is not going to come and
go  to be feminine, that is, a verb is not going to come,
not to come, the run is rare,
so instead we use
conditional random fields that what they are
looking for is to estimate the
conditional probability of i given x and basically the
change it makes is instead of having
probabilities  of mission we are going to have
lunar power functions and instead
of having transition probabilities
we are going to have pair potential functions they
have crazy names but they
are not crazy at all that would be the formula to
obtain the
probability conditional on a
sequence and a set of states
hidden is simply multiple
multiply each of the
potential functions we can have several
potential functions for each state an area  or
by which
wall potential
function all the
lambda-weighted multiplied potential functions are added
up throughout the sequence is an
exponential and that is adjusted by a
that zeta is a partition function
that all it does is adjust  since a
probability between 0 and 1 and good at
magic is on the moors the soft ones are
the parameters that the model adjusts and
that are what gives importance to the
potential function at first the
potential functions can be
any  function that returns you a
real value but what I normally used
before was functions that return 01
binary functions that, for example, is
if I am in state n and it is a good
person and x cn juan I give him a 1 if not I
give him a zero if  I am if the
previous state is an outsider and the word I
am seeing now ends in th I give it
11 if not a 0 then the soft ones are going
to take care of seeing how important that good
potential function is
by signs understood from the links it
is just a word and it returns a
vector of n dimensions so instead
of using these potential functions what
we might want to do is replace
each potential function an area by
one of the dimensions of the mbe dyn and the
pair potential functions are
simply a transition matrix
when we would already have a model that is
supposed to capture the structure of
our tags from conditional
brandon phillips and word in main
that was like a refresher so far in
case you missed it you'll basically read the
models framework logic and
random fields conditionals allow to model well and
capture the structure of the problem in
detail or and random fill conditionals
are like a discriminative version of
logic in models frameworks and combined with
word in 20 they allow to predict the problem
have time
now we are going to move on to  neural models
law develop from basic models and
reach long short term memories
the most basic  like having a meeting to the
simple below are the n-dimensional inputs
and to the river is the network output and
mentions there is a neuron for each
of the outputs and each neuron has
an associated set of weights
so that we do not get lost and it is more  easy
to visualize the input vector is going to
be that little ball the output vector is going to be
the other beautiful one there and in the entire layer of
neurons it is going to be the square of the
sigma
well this is useful if we want to make a
type of the model that we have said to
principle in which we classify each
word independently of the rest
I'm afraid simply dykstra and we hope
that it comes out in ip and that it will always be
the same tag now if we wanted to
incorporate the context we have options
or we add nothing it
saves the words next to it at 20
also on the input or we can use
recurrent neural networks that are
supposed to try to model the context
of a sequence model the information
that comes from before then the only thing  or what they
do is add and incorporate concatenate
the output of the previous state to the
input of our new state and in the
next state the new output will be
incorporated into the next one
this works if we have
short dependencies for example juan comes from
england
so he speaks english there is not much
distance between english england we
can get to model that for example
but if we have a longer dependency
today going on the subway to work it
took half an hour because it got stuck and
when it started someone vomited they had
to come to clean the car that is to
know  wagon and subway the dependency is
quite long to model that kind of
long sequences the lcd
m long short are incorporated into memories that what they
do is add a vector that has
a state of the internal memory let's say
and through different dense ones that is to say
different regions of a single layer,
let's say,
arm gates a first gate
that allows forgetting part of the
information  tion that you already have a second pair
of gates that allows us to incorporate
new information based on the word
we are seeing now and the
previous state and an output gate that,
based on the new memory state,
allows us to choose what we are going to do  to
go out to get as output
good and memory long shorts
allow modeling long dependencies
lupon is what we could do to
incorporate the context both the
left and the right of a word
is to use a long shorter memory forward
and backward and passing the sequence
of the keep 20 of our
classify phrase and concatenating each of
the exits of the favor and the backwards,
then take out with a soft max or something
the lakers for our nerd tagging problem
I did not say it but well each of those m
obviously  they have all the same
parameters let's say
well without more or less they continue
until here what we end up
implementing is simply
a combination  tion of this with the crf
from this paper we
implement an address in the 7 m
with cf the idea is that instead of having
as potential scenarios what we
had before they were saved Apr 20
we use the outputs of the lcd m
concatenated the potentials  of
transition are still a matrix
this already allows us to incorporate the context and
the structure of the problem but well in
our case what we had was that
we grabbed and did this for all the
words and then we did the post
processing instead of that what we are going to
to do was to incorporate in a way
the sequence of the line if it
were a representation of the
line and for that we added an stm
that for each of the lines made a
kind of gesture that is, we passed the entire
line and took out the  output that had as
condensed the information of all that
line and that was what we used as
input for the stm crf connecting rod this
gave us an improvement of almost 5% in relation
to the model only of  skin stm with crf that
we had before
now we are going to see a couple of metrics
good
as a review precision is the proportion
of correct predictions of the
predictions of a class recall is the
number of correct predictions in
relation to the total number of a
class and f1 is  as a kind of
crazy average between precision and recall
the greatest we are comparing
against a system that is based on a
rex is battery and some cases made
when they were important we took by hand and they
reached more or less 80% of f1
and the problem  What they had was that
most of the errors they had were
in the new documents, which
were precisely the most important, well,
we managed to pass 95%, what can be
seen is that most of the values
are around 90% and that the worst
values ​​correspond to the worst the
amounts of support let's say it is a
classic problem of
unbalanced classes let's say and well in the
list there is 'feeling' the f
n  or you have to say and f is the one as it is
only one sometimes we hit 100% of s&p
we love 0% we had only one example of
that in the test set in 30
we had only found about two examples
I think and we kept it just to see
what if sometimes we hit him sometimes
we were already improving that we were looking for more
but obviously there weren't many more examples it
was a pretty rare case
well the problem we had with this
was that when we showed the client
these metrics in general he looked at us
like that
and we tried to explain everything that we
explained just about who marks a
model if the structural is back
to ok and then what we did was
look for a metric that instead of
simply showing the tags shows the
champs so that it is a little more
understandable that you simply know
these are the chances that you want is
the proportion that we obviously hit
the metric below because already with the radar
you have an inside fighting and
all the chang dig looks bad on you  amos but it was much more
transparent much clearer for the
client as we have already advanced
and the last thing to compare is how
the metrics were before including the girls
in the model and bone doing the post-
processing and how they were after it is seen
that the final f1 before  it was almost 90%
not causing percent and then
95 percent passed I don't know if
with 6 percent
and that was the great improvement that we were able to
include
well so far what we have been
seeing doing the LCD combination  ms
with cf allow both to model the
context of the words and the
dependencies as well as to model the
structure of the problem in detail or whether
including the lines really helps us to
improve the model instead of leaving it the
information is outside
of what we are going to talk about now  it's from
another little problem we had which
was the unknown words when
you're working with
vocabulary problems generally some
words are going to be left out of the
voca  bulario in names new companies
new rare words of which you did not
have examples in your buttons that in
some way be able to model those words,
that is, you could simply make something
that is unknown and send all those
words to strangers but it is not a
very good modeling  you can add
more features like if they have a capital letter
or if they start with a capital letter if they are
all capital letters if they have any digits in
between if they have some kind of
ending a form or they start in
some way also with
regular expressions you can add the type as they
start or how they end  to know they are
type a verb type an adjective or so
or you can make a post model as
well as some extra information of
those words that you do not know or well
this is the option that we ended up
implementing
to the msf skins ls that  we already
had adds one
and information about rare words
with char in beijing if convolution to
neural networks e  n 20 letters would be
simply like the word in beijing, nothing
more than letters, that is, it would look for
each letter to have a representation of
a vector that if they are similar letters in
some ways in the vowels they would
all be together and the consonants that are
have certain similarities  aunts nearby
and from those vectors we pass them
through a combo solution and then through a
pull max and we get a representation
of that word hopefully
instead of that instead of doing it
by words we did it by line it
sounds kind of weird but if you think  what kind
of words are made up of
letters or morphemes and morphemes
are made up of letters and then
somehow with disastrous information it
should give you some meaning of the
words in fact in the paper they gave them
pretty good metrics
well and finally we incorporated
the  character representation of each
line together with the representation of
words that we already had we pass them with
l  to life in msf and this was the last
let's say improvement that gave us about a 12
percent improvement when we were already
above 95 percent per tag that it
is already quite difficult to continue advancing
let's say
finally take away your conclusions from the
entire project  and really integrating the
structure of the model instead of leaving it
out and then trying to make a
progress processing of things improved
the metrics a lot and was what
helps us to make the model more robust
looking for metrics that are
transparent to the client was quite
important  when it comes to lightening the
load of the pressure that the sound is
undermining and constantly wants to know
what you are doing,
this thing that happens is not very noticeable because we did not
get to show the code for the
time at the end of the days anyway,
I suppose it was recently  there is the definition
of the graph with tensor flow to
use framework as in support or a lot of
community when we start with these
years for the part of the crf we use a
country  truck, which is a library for
structured classification that is very
good, but when we wanted to integrate
crf with stm and we wanted to use it for
streep with whatever, they did not work, I mean,
we had a lot of problems and it
exploded everywhere, finally what
we did was we switched to tensor flow,
which  it has a little more community and by
reading the forum or talking to people
we were able to end up implementing the model
and the last thing was to try to find
similar problems that
we were talking about nothing here all the time in
artà gym when I started this
type of project a year and a half ago I had to
look for  some similar problem or something
to start what I wanted was something
that is similar to mine to see
what the state of the art is to see what
model they had used and simply
implement that or start implementing
that and then see how to improve
there was no  On the other hand, it was similar
to this, that is, long sequences, I
began to despair, I searched for all the
forums that there were  start creating
random accounts in places and ask
questions but I couldn't find anything and
finally I accepted that the closest thing
was ar tagging and I worked from
that and well just now as
we are putting together the post day for
the potato we look for some kind of return
datum towards the resemblance to be able to
show the example with code and between
all that search I was doing
I found someone in a remote place
on the internet who had asked
a very similar question, that is, he is looking for
a datum to be very similar to mine and how
it always happens that you are looking for a
particular question and someone
asked it in a remote place on the internet
about a year ago
where was nobody who knew anything is
magician 7000 and the saddest thing is not no
answer but a single answer that
says better to put it somewhere else and  in
another place obviously when he put it
there was nothing but the saddest thing of all is
when I realized that that person was
me anyway sometimes it's ca  Peace, there is no
problem similar to yours, start of the
closest thing,
the references and the code,
thanks
[Applause]
well, the person you were
looking for was here in Córdoba,
we have been working with that model and that
thing for three years, so
good  question that I wanted to ask you is
later if you want to chat we chat
when you pass the
character shipments they pass it on the convention they are
asked about the whole sentence and they
obtain a medina of characters
for all the words what
helped us the most  to incorporate that is not
let's say the meaning of let's say the
semantics as it would be to build an
instep behind that but it
gave us an mbe ding of the syntax
as let's say it helped us more in that
sense in my opinion because you put it to
run already  not knowing what they do or after
giving them higher numbers but but
let's say in my opinion let's say
we had a lot of
misspelled words or lines  badly written that
followed the syntax of what could
become one of a kind of
category, that's why I think let's say that it
must be drawing attention that how you are
going to get the mbe dyn of the line
cover as if they were words with
character
is another  thing let's say is like a thing
because we don't use it for
unknown words actually
the talk is very good well as emily says
we have been working on this for a while just
in case the implementation that they
did from scratch and if you know that
everything is implemented  this in which you were
his rfc mn the stm all
the whole the last one in which it is
by alert lines who can be without
his brother let's say it was not so difficult
that that part but how to
get to the solution where he
also decides to integrate it  on the 10th
the capable stm is not seen but he is until
I know what you have to do in what eras
it is not so trivial to do those who
separated from you we are going to grab to be
head of the  s the stm is and then put it
on display
then the second question that was the
question that I was going to ask them in reality
was that how they dealt with the
issue of the entire line of feeding
and not second they used they used
ortubé that  they used some model but
save me we found our vocabulary
because this niche of course wins
yes yes yes well there is a lot for example
I don't know I don't know how your client is in the particular case
but what the law info showed me to go to
and I deal with  that horrible body and
that corpus because it has a
lot of abbreviations so buttons
art article article without without accent
we are working with
highly technical and legal texts and there are
let's say murky things there
very specific vocabulary that's why we had
our own doctor come in and
anyway  we used to work with me
when training him and they did not try any
of the models of his words like
fast ex or any of those,
in fact it is a  something very similar very
similar in the model using the
charly of things using fast ex
improved the sides a little bit and that you can do it
if it were for fun
the move would be approved it would try everything
else chare may more parameters but
well the client is happy and  done
[Applause]
and